in the summer of 2020 i exploited a
loophole
to get my zero budget horror film to
become the number one movie
in the u.s box office this is that story
if you're thinking he kind of looks
familiar you're right my name is
christian nielsen
and i used to work at buzzfeed when i
left buzzfeed in 2019
i decided to focus on a feature film i'd
written and planned on directing this
past september but
then covet happened movie theaters
across the country were shuttered
our investors pulled out and seemingly
overnight
a project i'd worked on for about five
years just fell apart
i was devastated enter this fool you
remember him
eric tabak was the creator of some
really high brow buzzfeed content
like me eric left buzzfeed a few months
prior to the pandemic
he went to go star in his own youtube
series but also like me
the investors pulled out as soon as
covet hit i really felt for him here we
are following our passions and for
reasons
completely out of our control our dream
opportunities
seem to vanish on thursday may 7th eric
gave me a call out of the blue
he pointed out movies were only making
ten to twenty thousand dollars a day at
drive-ins and asked
with movie theaters closed and nothing
new being released did i think we could
make one of his youtube videos
go to number one in the box office
suddenly
i had an idea i told him about four
walling a distribution method where a
filmmaker rents out a theater for a flat
fee
and then keeps all the ticket sales i
said that if we were able to find a
closed theater rent their space for near
nothing
we could literally purchase every ticket
ourselves and the money would
essentially flow
right back into our own pockets
theoretically we wouldn't have to spend
a dollar he was in now we could have
filmed anything and it could have become
the number one movie in america
but i thought why not make it something
good maybe this could lead to something
else in the future
that saturday in about 12 hours i
knocked out the script for unsubscribe
a short horror film about five youtubers
who join a zoom call for their friend's
birthday
only to learn they're being hunted by an
internet troll despite writing it in
only one sitting
i was told it's pretty scary the next
day eric called a group of his friends
including former buzzfeeders michelle
carrey
zach kornfeld from the try guys and
somehow charlie tahan who you might
recognize from ozark and i am legend
they were all down and why not they were
all stuck at home bored
why pass up the opportunity to be the
number one movie in america
on monday may 11th just a few days after
eric first called
we started shooting we shot pretty much
all of unsubscribed virtually
over zoom in just four days if you can
give me a full-on
screen like on scream yeah
total budget zero dollars i started
editing
and eric worked to find us a theater and
that's when we hit our first
major problem cinemas were closed
every cinema eric called went straight
to voicemail and the few drive-ins that
were open
didn't care to screen our short film so
i called the west hampton beach
performing arts center
a small venue near my hometown that i
used to work at when i was in high
school
despite being closed they agreed to open
their doors for one day
only the rental fee literally one dollar
because they were closed so on wednesday
june 10th in front of a sold out
audience consisting
solely of eric and i we premiered
unsubscribe
we'd screen the film five times buying
out every seat for each showing
knowing the money would funnel right
back to us we spent
twenty five thousand four hundred eighty
eight dollars
and raked in 25 488
minus tax i reported the box office
numbers that night
to box office mojo and the numbers and
we waited eric and i nearly had a panic
attack
what if another movie made more than us
what if they didn't accept our
submission
what if we just wasted all of our time
the following day we went online and saw
unsubscribe was the number one movie
in america and overnight our
lives didn't change at least
not at first it wasn't until about a
week later when a local news site picked
up a facebook post that i written
that people started to notice in a big
way we woke up to find out we were
trending on twitter
we were in the washington post new york
magazine nbc the bbc
npr the irish times australian radio the
av
club most people thought the stunt was
brilliant
but we did have our critics there were
some people on film twitter that said
that we ruined the sanctity of the box
office
as if that's really a thing but you know
what it worked
not only did eric and i etch our names
in the annals of box office history but
we also got the film industry's
attention
a group of producers watched our film on
vimeo on demand
and approached us to make a feature film
and
we did eric and i just wrapped
production on a psychological thriller
called dash cam which is going to be
released next year and perhaps
even crazier the other month eric and i
screened unsubscribe
for seven consecutive days in chicago's
music box theater
qualifying us for the oscars i mean hey
if barely any short films screen in the
us in 2020
our chances of getting an oscar
nomination only increase right
so maybe what started as two guys losing
their dream opportunities
might just turn into an oscar now that'd
be a story
foreign